my name is Ali Klepper and I have guten
colorblindness when I first discovered
that I was colorblind I was in
kindergarten and my teacher noticed that
I was covering the sky purple and the
grass was brown they didn't think that
girls could be colorblind the most true
color I can see is yellow all the rest I
have a really hard time deciphering
definitely affects my daily life I am
extremely excited to see color for the
first time and if it actually works we
are going to the park I'm feeling super
nervous right now there is that chance
that they don't work but I'm very
excited too
so we are finally opening up for the
first time Maya chroma glasses I'm just
super excited
everything's so much more colorful like
these like these flowers over here
they're normally white when I don't have
these glasses on and now they're like
like a yellow this guy is really blue
that's crazy and when I have the glasses
on it's like just super red when I don't
have the glasses on like the leaves and
the flowers look really similar it's a
very like noticeable difference
everything is just so vivid I never
thought that colors would be so
beautiful